so Katherine very good evening to you so
corny what's it to be done presumably
you want it can it be done a free trade
agreement absolutely the sector has
almost unanimously been pressing for
this an ambitious free trade agreement
based on mutual recognition of
regulatory outcomes which would be to
give access for EU institutions to
London and the UK institutions to Europe
now we have had on what is on the face
of it a very pragmatic decision from the
Bank of England today explain what
they've done absolutely welcome this
what they've said is that on the basis
of regulatory cooperation European
institutions European banks will be able
to carry on operating through branches
rather than going to the expense of
setting up subsidiaries which cost them
a lot more in terms of capitalization
that would cost a lot more and those
costs would ultimately be passed to
consumers and it might encourage some
banks to remove their branches but there
I mean there is a big big caveat to this
which is of course that European and UK
regulators have to be seen to be acting
in tandem incorporation possible indeed
we need to remember we've started from a
position of complete alignment because
as we're part of Europe of course we are
and I think and the regulators are
perfectly capable of cooperating into
the future and this is what we'll be
looking for not just for the
relationship with EU and UK but actually
will be operating on the basis of
regulatory standards going forward as we
do at the moment now some people will
say hang on a minute
this is the Bank of England putting the
city status as a global financial center
ahead of financial stability in the UK
it isn't because what the governor is
clearly saying is that they will look at
how our counterparts in Europe cooperate
so he said there is that caveat clearly
in there and our regulators will always
be putting stability to the forefront
but I think we really need to welcome
what they've done here this is a global
gateway to capital which is important as
the Prime Minister says to EU as well as
it is the UK but from our perspective
it's a sector which generates 72 billion
of tax and a year to take an unnecessary
step which would increase costs and
deter people from continuing to operate
in London would be a mistake and I think
this has been a really positive
pragmatic
you don't think in any way shape or form
that the Bank of England has been lent
on by by the government here well I
couldn't comment on that but I think
this is a very pragmatic step that I
think this is after a really grueling
2017 a very pragmatic piece of good news
for the city we have a lot of work to do
next year but this is a good way to end
this year look I guess the real risk
though is it's a No Deal sonare and now
potentially becomes absolutely
catastrophic for the city well a No Deal
scenario has always been a bad thing for
both the city and for Europe and I'm we
have a lot of work to do next year but
it's perfectly possible in to make a
sensible solution here we need we need
clarity around transition as early as
possible next year we need progress on
this ambitious at trading relationship
but that's all entirely possible and
today has been a step in the right
direction optimistic I Catherine that
the regulator's within the EU will be
happy to play ball with this I mean
we've had some fairly whacko ideas that
have come out of Europe in recent years
such as a financial transaction tax
which obviously would be complete and
affirmative to us here in the UK I think
it's in everybody's interests and look
for 10 years from the crash it's in
everybody's interest to look at
International regulatory standards what
we need to keep global financial systems
safe
EU regulators will be as focused on that
as our regulators are and regulators
that there's I think every reason to
believe that regulators will be able to
continue cooperating into the future I
guess the flip side of that though is
what freedom will the city and the Bank
of England as its regulator have to
deviate from European regulations that
it won't I mean Mark Carney for example
has said very clearly dropping the cap
on bankers bonuses would be a very
welcomed priority for the city post
brexit the free trade agreement that
were advocating the ambitious chapter of
a free trade agreement covering services
would lay down arrangements so that
regulated regulations could diverge if
if either side wanted but it would set
down a arbitration mechanism a way of
judging that and so that we could stay
aligned as far as possible so there
would be freedom to move but there's an
arbitration mechanism in there do you
think ultimately this is going to mean
that the UK regulates financial
institutions from Europe role as it does
with the Americans the Asian banks and
so on thinks they have regulatory
cooperation develops but what we're
proposing is something which would give
the UK its autonomy whilst working
against the backdrop of international
regulatory standards and cooperation and
lastly Catherine any thoughts on what we
heard from Michel Barney today on the
transition period um and that's roughly
what we were expecting wasn't is roughly
what we're expecting I think what I am
tempted to say he would say that
wouldn't he he would start from a fairly
tough position we've got to negotiate as
I say there's a lot of work to be done
in 2018 and I we will see things moved
transition is as important to e27
as it is to us because it's going to
take time to extricate our to move apart
smoothly and carefully all right
Catherine McGinnis from the City of
London Corporation always very good to
see you thank you for joining me